flats or drums
um uh Flats why was there so much of a
struggle because I didn't know what
either of them really meant bro we like
them Flats I'm from Texas
it's gone chicken wings oh I don't eat
chicken no what do you eat my love I'm a
vegetarian yeah yeah you do you eat
chicken wings I used to well I used to
because I'm vegan now
I don't know
is everyone vegan on the CAF are you
vegetarian no
no thank Godly tree respectfully flats
or drums flats or drums for chicken
wings
I don't know what that means I don't get
people that like drumsticks it's too
much work I feel like there's more
chicken on the flag
smoothly you know my father told me one
thing he taught me how to eat a flat in
one bite
you know oh the thighs oh sorry uh uh uh
drums what did he say
you know what this is a lot about you
saying and I respect you for